the myth we're testing is whether or not
we could use a fire extinguisher it's
like in the movie gravity where Sandra
Bullock's character uses a fire
extinguisher in three - redirection
herself - and propel herself in space
one
[Music]
[Applause]
my coven Eliza uncommon is there clearly
our budding space cadet had next to no
directional control i just obliterated
the finish line it was beautiful from
the inside all I saw is just like mist
around me and I see like a pole but it
was Elijah's first ever time firing a
fire extinguisher his failure may have
been operational in experience rather
than experimental so he's getting
another chance
obstacle course fire extinguisher test
and three two one
[Music]
oh go ahead
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was perfect we actually saw you as
steering yourself with the fire
signature and it looked like it worked I
managed to not knock over the finish
line this time that's a huge bonus
because you were about to you saw it at
the last second adjusted your direction
and managed not to knock it over and you
were almost going to look for the first
part of the test it was ambiguous
whether Elijah was shifting his
direction or whether he was just pushing
the obstacles out of the way but in the
finish line it was totally unambiguous
he was heading towards the right hand
goalpost
he gave a blast in that direction and
made himself go cleanly through without
hitting anything that's what I call a
successful test a successful test
requires a repeatable result gave
achieved some balance with the force
jessee's up next hovercraft
obstacle course test in three two
[Music]
he's setting all the obstacles
[Music]
it was a lot harder than when it looks
you hit everything yeah you can pretty
much say that I destroyed the solar
system Jesse's test was not nearly as
successful as Elijah's he'd been hit I
think every single planet on his way
however it was clear he was changing his
direction with the fire extinguisher
it's just that it was happening at a
much slower rate than it seems to happen
in the movie so the fire extinguisher
has to overcome a ton of inertia which
means every reaction is much slower than
each of the people testing expects it to
be
all right Valerie in three two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
yep and a similar result for valerie
seals the deal all signs point to the
fire extinguisher lacking enough thrust
to overcome and control the momentum of
our astronauts in the same way it did in
the movie
alright guys we have gathered all the
evidence I think we can how do you want
to call this myth I want to call this
myth busted and for three reasons unlike
the movie we couldn't reverse direction
we were barely able to steer and we
couldn't gain control when we were
spinning out of control
alright I think you're totally right
it's completely busted busted busted
busted busted busted busted okay three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
you